- [Narrator] Before there was all of this,
(upbeat music)
there was this.
- Welcome to "Blockbuster Video".
- [Narrator] But then
Netflix changed everything.
Once a DVD distributor.
- It's easy
- [Narrator] It became a streaming pioneer
revolutionizing the way people watch TV
and movies.
Other networks and
studios raced to catch up.
And now Disney, HBO and
NBC are chipping away
at Netflix's market.
And in April, 2022.
- Report from Netflix
saying it's lost subscribers
For the first time in a decade.
- [Narrator] That was enough
to send its stock plummeting
35% in a single day.
Netflix's worst day since 2004.
And though the stock
hasn't fully recovered,
the company made gains
in the third quarter
adding 2.4 million subscribers.
So what happened to the
streaming giant this year
and how is it bouncing back?
Netflix lost 200,000 subscribers
in the first quarter of 2022
instead of the 2.5 million
it projected to gain.
Netflix said that completely shutting down
its service in Russia
following the country's attack
on Ukraine resulted in the net loss.
The company also attributed the loss
to increased subscriber churn.
Part of that came from a price increase
in January.
- It wasn't the first time
that Netflix had raised prices
but it was a price increase
that triggered new sort
of consumer defections.
- [Narrator] Along with
increased competition
and inflation, it also had to contend
with another problem, password sharing.
- These are over a
hundred million households
that already are choosing to view Netflix.
They love the service.
We just gotta get paid
at some degree for them.
- [Narrator] So the streamer moved
to make a change.
- We're not trying to
shut down that sharing
but we're gonna ask you to pay a bit more
to be able to share.
- [Narrator] And that wasn't all.
As the company tried to control costs,
it laid off more than 450 people
over the next few months.
- The stock decline triggered a series
of changes that the
company is still enacting.
So one of the biggest changes that came
after that decline that was announced
that same day was that Netflix
would add an ad supported tier of service.
- [Narrator] But those
changes aren't about face
for the streamer which
has famously assured ads
and embraced sharing.
- Those who have followed Netflix know
that I've been against the complexity
of advertising and a big
fan of the simplicity
of subscription.
- [Narrator] That simplicity worked
in the company's favor at a time
when growing was the goal.
- In the early days of the rise
of streaming and really the streaming wars
what helped convince consumers
to cut their cable bill was
that Netflix was flexible
and you could binge series
whenever you wanted.
You weren't encumbered with ads
in the same way that you were on cable
and you could share what you paid
for with family and friends.
- [Narrator] And in 2020,
that model really worked
especially during the pandemic.
The company's vast content library
and binge able series
drew in customers confined
to their homes.
The streamer's share price rose from $319
in March of 2020 to
over $550 in early 2021.
It also added a record
37 million new users
in 2020 on the strength of popular shows
like "The Queens Gambit",
"Tiger King".
- My name's Joe Exotic, and this is Sarge.
- [Narrator] And "Bridgerton".
- I wish to be entertained.
- There's a subset of companies
that benefited intensely from the pandemic
and the way people's
lives changed during it.
And a commonality that you see
in those companies is
that when times are good
it's very hard to imagine
times becoming bad again.
- [Narrator] But things did get bad
as the pandemic wore on and people started
to leave their homes.
In 2021, the company's
growth began to slow.
- COVID created a lot of noise
in how to read the situation,
boosted us a lot in 2020.
And then in 2021, I think
we thoughtfully said
it was mostly pull forward
which was the logical conclusion.
But now coming into 2022
that you know doesn't really hold.
- [Narrator] April wasn't
the first time in 2022
that Netflix's stock sank.
In January, after the company forecasted
slower subscriber growth,
shares fell 20% in after hours trading.
- In the streaming business,
the number of subscribers
that are paying you
to watch your content is really one
of the most important metrics
of a company's health.
- [Narrator] But while streaming services
like Disney plus or
HBO Max have other ways
of generating revenue--
- Netflix almost entirely is
in the business of streaming.
And so that is, its lifeblood.
And when it loses streaming subscribers
that is a problem for the
heart of its business.
- [Narrator] And with a crowded field
of streamers, gaining new subscribers
can be difficult.
- The challenge that all
the streaming companies
are having now, particularly in the US
is they have acquired
most of the customers
that are ever going to pay to stream.
They have to figure out
how to make more money
from those people than
what that puts front
and center for all of these services
is the importance of competing on content.
- [Narrator] After April stock decline,
the company scrambled to act quickly.
- There have been rivals that have been
in the business of
selling ad supported tiers
for quite some time.
There have been other streaming services,
Spotify for one that has
always been very stringent
about password sharing.
So these are levers that existed
before that Netflix hadn't pulled.
And so I think that moment sort
of raises the question
of was Netflix too slow
to do all that it could have
to avoid the severity of this moment?
- [Narrator] This year,
Netflix's share price
is down more than 60%
but the streamer reported something
of a turnaround in the September quarter.
The company added twice
as many subscribers
as expected in Q3,
sending shares up in after hours trading
immediately after its report.
- Thank God we're done
with shrinking quarters.
Everything the company's focused on
whether that's on the content side,
on marketing, lowering
prices to the ad supported,
the paid sharing, the
thoughtful approach we're
doing there lines us up
for a good next year.
- [Narrator] Looking
ahead, the streamer says
it's new ad supported tier will launch
in November for 6.99 a month,
and the company this week laid
out some of the steps
it will take to crack
down on password sharing
and make it easier
for subscribers sharing accounts
to make their own.
- Those are the two strategic elements
that it really needs to nail at this point
because those will prove to shareholders
whether or not the the
promises and decisions
that executives have made are going
to bear fruit and set the company
on a more sustainable path in the future.
(upbeat music)